we are now learning about the existence
of a literal not proverbial pandemic
playbook that Donald Trump and the White
House had in their possession
they'd had it for years and they just
ignored it as they continued to insist
coronavirus is no big deal and
everything's just fine this is a
color-coded 69 page long playbook it's a
manual for fighting pandemics if they
simply followed it they didn't have to
come up with anything new they didn't
have to get the information was all
right there if they simply followed the
69 page document that they had all along
that they were briefed on in 2017 by the
outgoing Obama administration think
about how much better off we would all
be right now think about how many fewer
deaths we would be on target to have the
playbook dates to 2016 and the PlayBook
was created because in 2014-15 we had
Ebola lessons were learned so a playbook
was put together this is called
iteration it's called learning the
PlayBook was made in 2016 it was turned
over to the Trump administration in 2017
they were briefed on the PlayBook in
2017 then of course Donald Trump
disbanded the pandemic response team we
know where we are today as a result of
that and as you all probably realized by
now pandemics are an issue of national
security this is a national security
document it's the National Security
Council's pandemic playbook 69 pages and
it was just ignored simply ignored like
it doesn't exist and and this is another
interesting thing on Monday I gave a
list of what should Trump have done and
when should he have done it now at the
time I wasn't aware of this PlayBook but
many of the things I mentioned including
the timelines are literally in this
playbook right at the start so I one of
the things I said was months ago
that's when the government needs to
start obtaining securing and
distributing personal protective
equipment including masks and gloves and
looking at getting the ventilators to
where they need to be the PlayBook says
one of the things you do at the first
sign of the pandemic is you ask is there
sufficient
PPE personal protective equipment for
healthcare workers who are providing
medical care if the answer is no should
the strategic national stockpile be
released to States Trump started talking
about this eight days ago nine days ago
maybe the PlayBook says just like I said
on Monday that should have been done in
January at the absolute latest Trump
simply didn't do it it was in the
playbook it was in the document that
they were given the funding stuff the
the checks and and the stimulus I said
on Monday you need to start negotiating
and planning the bailout early so that
the money can actually get to people
when they need it we are now almost in
April with luck people will get their
$1200 checks in three weeks and that's
only half because remember you'll get a
direct deposit in roughly three weeks
assuming it passes the house later today
if you file taxes in 2018 or 2019 filed
your 2018 or 2019 taxes and received a
refund via direct deposit that's how
you'll get your check your 1200 bucks in
three weeks the other half is unlikely
to get there twelve hundred bucks for an
additional three to five weeks beyond
that the playbook says plan in advance
with legislators to have the money ready
they didn't do it it's actually shocking
that the advice is so obvious that even
I who know nothing about this stuff I
was able to put together a list of stuff
that should have been done that we now
know mirrors much of what was in this
pandemic response playbook and they had
the playbook they didn't have to do the
thinking part they just had to do the
doing part and they didn't do it they
had a physical playbook with
instructions and they ignored all of it
and what we now I mean listen dieta they
there's always these questions that you
don't start assigning blame in the
middle of stuff but at the same time if
you think you need someone else leading
the cause you do have to assign blame
when this is all said and done is
anybody going to be held accountable and
what I mean by that is when the death
toll stops and when we get beyond this
which hopefully will be as soon as
humanly possible are there gonna be
consequences or is Trump gonna get
himself another four years because as
we've talked about yesterday
earlier in the week the approval rating
for Trump is up the portion of the
population satisfied with his handling
of this is up and what I've really come
to realize during this coronavirus
pandemic is I really prefer my dystopias
to be only in the fiction books that I'm
reading and not in reality I love
dystopian science fiction and yet I'm
finding myself struggling to read any of
it right now because it's all feeling
just a little bit too real check this
out the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a premium membership to
Skillshare for two months completely
free skill shares the online learning
community with thousands of classes on
almost anything you can imagine always
taught by experts they have classes on
drawing painting photography video
editing web design running a small
business and much more I recently took a
very interesting class called simple
productivity how to accomplish more with
less and got a bunch of great personal
productivity tips out of it we should
allow ourselves a little time every week
to either get creative keep your brain
sharp learn something new it's great for
mental health and almost all the classes
are under an hour so it's very easy for
someone who's busy to take advantage of
it with skill share you can discover a
new passion explore something you didn't
know you would enjoy but there's also
plenty of classes for people with
experience so you can just get better at
something you're already good at and
again the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for two whole months giving
you access to every class Skillshare
offers check it out I put the link right
underneath this video